it is no exaggeration to say that we're
living
in a mental health epidemic we're in the
midst of a mental health
crisis anxiety and depression are
reaching levels we've never seen before
a united nations
number recently said that more people
are dying
by suicide more people are taking their
own lives
than are dying from natural disasters
and armed conflict
combined right so so the biggest danger
that we're facing is ourselves is our
mind and of course
all mental illness all mental distress
has its roots in trauma
a recent theory hypothesized by
neuroscientist robin carthart harris is
known as the entropic brain
theory essentially when people during
formative periods of their
lives are traumatized or slayed are
sidelined experienced an involuntary
killing of the ego some
intense betrayal during a very
vulnerable period in their lives they
are
indented by this assault this this
trauma becomes
a part of how they see the world it
becomes the lens through which they now
see
everything they develop a kind of hyper
vigilance the ego and their whole
sense of self the way they orient
themselves in the world
becomes hyper vigilant becomes hyper
sensitive the ego becomes a tyrant the
ego
turns against itself so to speak and
this hyper vigilance afflicts the
depressed
and the anxious person to no end
chris lethbe out of philosopher of mind
out of australia says that we have these
these lenses through which we see the
world right we don't see the world
directly we see the world through our
cultural upbringing and our
preconceptions and our cognitive biases
and our blind spots and so on and so
forth our past experience colors
are world and we see with these lenses
and we see through
these lenses but what we don't always
see are the lenses themselves and on the
other side
of trauma what happens is our lenses
become thwarted
our lenses become become transformed
become
weaponized our our lenses now
see the world less clearly and see the
world in fact only through the eyes of
that
trauma right once you're driven off a
cliff at 60
miles per hour you don't let happiness
in the door without a full
cavity search and so the anxiety and the
depression and the lenses of perception
and these
these become these rigid patterns of
thinking they they calcify the world is
against you
nothing's going to work out i need to be
afraid everywhere i go these
these these these rigid thought patterns
calcify the ego becomes
weaponized it becomes it becomes an
autoimmune disorder of the self and so
what happens is these people can no
longer
exist with any kind of equanimity
they're perpetually
in a state of fibrillating anxiousness
in the words of jamie wheel and what
psychedelics seem to do
it seems to make them so effective both
for treating ptsd ocd
anxiety depression all of these things
according to the work of robin carhart
harris as they functionally shake the
snow globe
they dissolve the self right and by
dissolving the self you dissolve the
rigid thought patterns what chris
lethebe
describes it as is they make you aware
of your lenses of perception the lenses
you see through and the lenses you see
with become
visible the possessor can see his own
lenses and in that moment of seeing your
own lenses
seeing your own patterns revisiting your
trauma getting to the worm at the core
the root
of the neurosis the root of the issue
from this dispassionate
distancing that takes place during the
psychedelic experience this out of
body moment is an open heart surgery of
the psyche a moment
an opportunity for reformation
transformation
re-programming re-patterning
reformatting right and this is a real
thing they call it fear extinction and
memory reconsolidation over at maps.org
and so
the space that is opened up the space
that is occasioned by these psychoactive
compounds
could do for psychiatry and mental
health what the telescope did for
astronomy and the microscope did for
biology
and i'm not the only person who has said
this far
from it we we reframe
we reframe our our mental distress as a
problem to be solved
to a problem that solves us
that's a wonderful quote that i came
across
and so if if we're willing to
to submit to deploying these
psychoactive compounds in the spaces of
psychotherapy and mental health
we could engender a revolution
psychedelic is
psychedelic therapy is big business
nowadays and what's more important than
ever is that the companies that enter
this space
are are leading are leading with
intention and are leading with
consciousness right that they're not
just themselves trying to monetize
fed only by the profit motive but that
their inspiration is
a real a real um
call to to to make a dent in the mental
distress
space you know to really um
alleviate suffering and and and and
and and and i'll provide an opportunity
for people to remake themselves you know
we've all experienced
trauma and finally you know perhaps we
can
create more and more healthy spaces to
absolve ourselves from our grief to
metabolize our grief and
and this is this is something i'm very
passionate about i'm very passionate
about
psychoactive interventions and the the
future of psychotherapy and
and and and and enter and coming to the
space with
with integrity because if there is no
integrity then
well then we're wasting a huge
opportunity
let the better angels of our nature lead
the way
in the psychedelic revolution